if you had to stop a horrifying
apocalypse from taking over the world
what would you do you'll have to face
fallen angels and terrifying monsters
and demons and you'll have to fight
against the only friend you've ever had
to save the world I'm going to break
down the mistakes made what you should
do and how to beat the world of Berserk
this guy's soon going to be literally
forced to watch all of his close friends
get ripped torn crushed by terrifying
demons guts here is a lone wolf
mercenary for hire and the fiercest
warrior in the world or at least in his
mind he is and he's taking part in a
bloodthirsty War sieging the enemy's
Castle they break through their defenses
and begin to kill off every guy here
coming across this Giant Warrior
defending the castle the Army he's a
part of refuses to fight this Psycho
Killer and guts gets tired of waiting
and challenges him to a one-on-one
battle to the death if I was guts I
would know that the only way to take
this man down would be to go right
through his sweat drenched balls let me
explain bonzuso here is known as the
30-man Slayer and overall badass but if
we notice when our army entered the
castle this guy was keeping all of our
men at Bay just by trash talking them
like the Rockwood at WrestleMania
impressive but a problem this guy was
using his mythical status to instill
fear in our troops we cannot let that
happen no matter how impressive it is
that he is vastly outnumbered by our
troops and this means that he is smarter
than he looks and is carrying a battle
ax which means that if he doesn't cut
through our armor he could very well
Crush our bones anyways so that means we
have to be super careful and we can't
rush him because of this reason there
are two tactics that we could use and
one being way less risky and the other
plan involves getting up real close and
personal with his balls and his sheer
size alone on top of the weight of the
armor and the weapon that he carries
means that he's probably way slower than
us and so taking all of this into
account I would stay just Out Of Reach
of his first several swings because this
will Tire him out and the first sign
that I see that he's starting to slip
I'm gonna head behind him while staying
low and take advantage of his
vision and then use the opening under
his legs which is very common in armor
in order for maneuverability I would
simply take my sword and chop apart his
manhood right here as this alone would
the man forever and from there
we could take him as a prisoner or
brutally kill him or we could just leave
him there to bleed out because he will
be in too much pain to defend himself at
all drawing his sword he launches at the
enemy with powerful moves no one has
ever seen and he quickly slices through
the stomach and splits his head in two
the Army cheers and goes on to win the
rest of the battle with him not
realizing that he's been watched by this
man and his team a man that will change
the course of history after the battle
guts takes his pay and quickly leaves
for his next adventure but that's when a
group of Bandits start charging towards
him on alert he takes out his sword and
defends his salary the men attack him
but he quickly defends himself and
manages to take some of them out and
just then another Warrior leaps at him
but he cuts him down and the helmet
comes off and gut sees that it's a woman
she lunges at him with speed and
precision but guts manages to overpower
her and he tries to take off her head
but he is stopped by the team's leader
this man's name is Griffith he tells
guts to lower his sword so they can talk
but guts doesn't listen and attacks but
the fight is already over and he
realizes that Griffith has already
critically injured him with his
lightning quick moves a few days later
he wakes up all healed and finds out
that he is in a cap belonging to the
greatest mercenary group in the land the
band of the hawk Griffith approaches
guts and offers him to work for his
group but guts doesn't trust him and
challenges him to a duel instead
Griffith reluctantly takes out his sword
and repeats his insane moves on guts but
finds out that he is a Madman biting his
sword and taking him to the ground
Griffith gets dirty and finally manages
to win the duel and guts admits defeat
and tells him that he'll work for the
band of the Hawks Griffith smiles and
tells him that they will work towards
achieving his dreams of getting their
very own kingdom but no one here has
anything idea that obtaining this
Kingdom will come at the ultimate price
over the next few years guts takes part
in many battles for Griffith and the
group gets larger and larger and gains
more notoriety and makes an even bigger
name for themselves and one day during
their latest battle they face their
toughest opponent yet the men tell guts
not to go down this basement because
down there is a 200 year old monster
waiting for them inside but guts doesn't
listen and charges end there like a dog
without a brain rushing inside he
stepped into a pool of blood and smells
the fresh stench of rotting corpses and
he comes across this giant demon
nosferatuzad guts acts without thinking
and uses his giant legendary sword
against him and he manages to make a
single cut into this monster and this
pisses it off suddenly this demon begins
shape-shifting into a huge Minotaur
Beast attacking guts he gets injured and
realizes that this demon can't be
stopped and just then his men show up
but quickly gets slaughtered as well and
griffith then shows up and tries to save
him and the two take pot shots at the
demon and knocks Griffith out cold and
is about to skin him alive when it
realizes what's exactly around his neck
the Egg of the king this demon is
shocked and suddenly stops fighting and
then he begins chuckling
and warns guts that this man is not his
friend and when this man's ambition
collapses death will come and no one
will be able to escape it suddenly
growing ginormous Wings the demon blasts
out of the castle and leaves guts with
more questions than answers the next day
both men recover and guts questions
Griffith about the necklace what is it
and what does it mean Griffith's voice
tenses up slightly when he responds and
says that he got it long ago from a
fortune teller lady and he mentions that
whoever possesses this necklace was
destined to obtain the world in exchange
for their own flesh and blood of course
whatever that means but then they're
interrupted by the king and his
Entourage and he tells them how
impressed he is with their team and
griffith thanks him and he throws an eye
at the King's Daughter and she throws
one back at him
Griffith you naughty boy and no one here
has any idea that this mistake will
trigger the events of Griffith's demise
that night Griffith offers guts a new
terrifying job to commit murder he tells
him that not everyone in this Kingdom
likes them including this one guy who is
second in line to the throne Griffith
gets serious and says that this man
views him as a threat and will likely
have him killed soon and he tells guts
to go kill this man without question as
a favor to him and guts like an idiot
accepts okay this is why I would have
killed my target with a bowl of
blueberries let me explain the man
Griffith is setting us up to kill the
brother to the king a real psychopath
and US killing any royal family member
will screw us over big time it has to
even if we aren't caught because as a
mercenary group being paid to fight for
the king that's not exactly an uncommon
thing back in the Middle Ages but the
fact is is that mercenaries are known to
be only loyal to whoever pays them them
the most meaning that our reputation is
not exactly the greatest and think about
it this Kingdom has 5 000 soldiers that
are only here because they want to get
paid they're just commoners surfs they
have no alliances and we live right
outside the castle so let's play this
out a royal family member gets murdered
the moment we start to get closer to the
royal family coincidence I think not a
member of the royal family getting
murdered will make our band of the Hawks
the first suspect and this king is
powerful enough to kill us all if he
can't find the suspect and when you add
to the fact that there are many examples
of mercenaries throughout history
betraying their clients this means that
it's not out of the world to assume that
we would be guilty also the idea of
trying to assassinate a royal is way too
much work and way too risky instead I
would utilize certain poisonous plants
like wolf Spain which is a poisonous
plant that grows in Central Europe only
20 milliliters of this bad boy is needed
to kill somebody and death usually
occurs within two to six hours which is
exactly the time frame we need but the
best part about this is that the wolf
Spain poison and can also act upon
contact with skin through open wounds
which means we could smudge some on our
Target's open wounds the next time we go
into battle or stuff it into his mouth
since the poison has a delayed reaction
and the first signs of being poisoned
are common tummy troubles and this means
that the king will think that our target
has sustained wounds or caught an
infection from Battle rather than him
being poisoned later he sneaks into the
castle killing this one guard and he
slithers his way into his Target's room
taking him out he suddenly hears someone
approaching through this door launching
at the Intruder he puts a hole in his
second victim and realizes that he just
accidentally murdered a kid this man's
kid gots eyes widen as he tries to help
him but it's no use and just then he
hears more sounds of incoming
reinforcements and quickly fights his
way out of the castle getting shot in
the arm with this Arrow he manages to
jump over the castle walls and escape
the news spreads quickly across the
kingdom but nobody can focus on it for
long the next day they resume their 100
Year battle with this other powerful
Kingdom and they get into another bloody
battle Griffith's right hand Whoa man
kaska here stops to take on this
mid-level boss I'll call him ugly face
because he nasty and he overpowers her
in cornice her at the edge of this Cliff
some of her reinforcements arrive but
they get slaughtered in seconds and ugly
face makes fun of her and prepares to
strike her down but she is saved by guts
at the last moment he quickly knocks
this guy back but this pisses him off
uglyface whips out a new move and
prepares to use his ultimate spear
technique passed down through his family
for 140 years but instead instantly gets
his ass kicked guts checks on kaska but
she almost falls off this Cliff he tries
to catch her and holds on for dear life
but ugly face shoots an arrow in him
last minute and the two fall down this
giant cliff and come crashing down into
freezing cold water later washing up
ashore guts takes himself and koska to
this cave stripping off their freezing
cold clothes they try to warm each other
up a few hours later kaska wakes up
warmer than a Bento Box but she reveals
that she has angry at guts for being a
better man than Griffith ever was to her
now not fully healed yet guts in koska
try to make their escape but run into
another Ambush and meet the same guy
from earlier ugly face and he laughs and
tells them that he'll soon torture them
with a torture technique passed down
through his family for 200 years his men
attack but guts and kaska managed to put
up a good fight and guts tells koska to
go get help and stubborn as hell she
refuses for a sec and then finally tells
him that she'll be back soon guts
continues to take on the soldiers
deflecting arrows and taking swings
ruthlessly killing dozens of soldiers in
this bloodbath it is
meanwhile kaska runs into some more
soldiers and they pin her down trying to
fight back and she is saved Just In Time
by Griffith and his men and she begs
them to go save guts back at Gus's
position he Slaughters man after man and
decapitates more sons and fathers the
enemies start to get even more terrified
as they surround him and he pulls some
serious God of War moves and cements his
status as a legend among men moments
later Griffith's men finally arrived but
they see hundreds of corpses leading up
to guts resting on this tree and hanging
on to dear life they hail him as a hero
and give him the name the 100 man Slayer
catching up to the leader of the bad
guy's ugly face they head back home
later that night this Rando teammate
tells koska Griff considers her and guts
essential to the group and she finally
gets some much needed validation he
hands her some magic powder to go apply
on guts reaching him he tells her how
seeing Griffith chase a dream is
inspiring and he made him question if he
should go find his own dream and this
shocks koska and she tells him to focus
on the current War at hand for tomorrow
there will be even more Bloodshed in the
morning another battle takes place
sending animal corpses over the wall
more soldiers clashed swords and Spilled
blood more and more of the King's Men
keep dying and he begins to get worried
that they'll never be able to take down
this castle and just then a squad of
lethal Black Knights exit the castle
with a fighting force more powerful than
they could even imagine unable to breach
the castle the king Retreats for the day
and that night he gathers his counselors
to give him some much needed advice they
warn him that most of his men have been
killed including their own Legion of
knights they can't keep up this fight
for much longer and then Griffith
sitting at the table in careful silence
tells the king that his group of
mercenaries will be able to defeat the
enemy all 30
000 men if the king lets them and gives
the order the king receives Griffith's
confident case and accepts his offer the
next day Griffis group of 5 000 men
prepare for battle getting the layout he
is warned of what their up against 20
high-tech cannons an Endless Sea of
incoming arrows pounds upon pounds of
heavy Stone catapults gallons of burning
all resting up above on the castle walls
and Legions of the enemy's very own holy
Purple Rhino Knights this is getting way
too out of hand for no reason if I was
them I would have simply offered myself
up sort of I would have offered up some
of my men in a sort of Trojan Horse kind
of example let me explain the enemy's
Castle is situated in front of a
mountain that we can see right here and
this means that they only need to defend
one area of their Castle which they have
been doing brilliantly unfortunately and
means that we can't sneak up on them or
divide their attention by attacking them
from numerous sides however if I was the
king I would have realized that there
was a much easier way to attack this
Castle in a way where we would have
never even needed the band of the Hawks
however impressive they are I would have
gotten in there by doing what a military
group known as the Visigoths did during
the destruction of Rome in 410 CE it's
noted that on the battlefield there are
destroyed Siege Towers left and right
over here and that is something that we
can absolutely use we're going to have
this plant start at night I'm going to
have my infantry along the outer walls
on both sides of this mountain while I
would put all of my archers hidden
Within These destroyed Siege blocks and
towers and then when everybody's ready I
would then offer some of my most
handsome soldiers up to swing the deal
as servants because we've been battling
each other for all of these years and
once they open up the castle doors to
accept my servants I would then order my
arches to begin firing down upon them in
a sort of rather creepy Barrage at night
it would create chaos at first and then
once my archers are done and then timing
it right I would then order my men
stationed on both sides of the castle to
begin invading through the open door
that's how I would do it without even
needing the band of the hawk the enemy
prepares for battle as they are greeted
by ugly face at their front door he says
him and his men escaped and will now
fight alongside them but they don't
realize that this is a trojan horse
meanwhile Griffith's men charged down
from the field and split his Force into
two punching through the enemy's line he
uses his light cavalry's Mobility to
power through the enemy orders his heavy
Calvary to take them head-on while their
archers Deploy on both of their flanks
thinking soon he will have them cornered
The Archers deploy their Hellfire arrows
and try to break Griffith's formation
and he soon orders his men to retreat
the enemy's Commander thinks something
is off but they're arrogant in general
then steps in and orders everyone to go
chase after Griffith and his men and
they quickly Corner Griffith's men near
this River and there they make their
last stand to destroy the enemy as they
Advance the smoke from the battlefield
quickly blackens the air and no one can
see anything and the enemy doesn't
notice a squadron of Griffiths soldiers
approaching the castle walls finally
infiltrating the base Griffith's men
quickly began killing bad guys and koska
and her crew unmasked and also begin
killing the rest of the bad guys
distracted uglyface uses this
opportunity to try and fight his way out
aggressively fighting against koska and
taking her down these steps he distracts
her and pins her against the wall
claiming to have just used his family's
1 000 year old destruction character he
talks too much and thank you Lord kaska
steals her sword and quickly kills this
guy's BS family ancestry techniques oh
thank you back to the battlefield guts
tries to take on the leader of the
Purple Rhino Knights and his men try to
help him but they get their bones and
flesh ripped apart in an instant the sky
reigns with their blood this guy charges
at guts but misses and guts attacks from
the air slamming his head into the sand
floor and that's when the commander
suddenly realizes that his castle has
been overrun by Griffith's men and they
are now surrounded his men run away and
leave him behind and he gets swiftly
killed by Griffith signifying the end of
The 100 Year War later Griffith and crew
returned to the kingdom they serve and
are greeted as Gods among men and that
night they get elevated all to
Knighthood by the king and there he puts
on a lavish ball arriving at the venue
guts gets a little overwhelmed with all
the love and affection and he needs a
breather so he goes outside and he meets
up with casca she says she'd be more
comfortable with a sword and guts tells
her that she looks good and this comment
was his biggest Best Mistake he tells
kaska that helping Griffith Chase his
dream of owning his own kingdom has
inspired guts to find his own dream and
that he truly is considering to leave
the group to go find it kaska is stunned
but their conversations cut short by the
king who makes a speech and tells
everyone to basically get really drunk
inside kaska sees Griffith dancing with
the princess and gets super bummed up
because apparently she can't get over
Angel Face Griffith anyways but then
guts dances with her and they both
forget about their deep conversation
that they literally had and later guts
drinks at the pub and talks to one of
his buddies about what he and casca
spoke about and his buddy suggests that
he should bring Costco with him since
they've been getting closer wink wink
but guts tells him that she is stuck on
Griffith like velcro covered in super
glue and his buddy tells him that she'll
never have Griffith because Griffith has
set his sight on achieving the best and
how is he gonna do that by wooing the
princess and since it is now peace time
a general like him will never achieve
much more in any Kingdom unless he pulls
something crazy off like like marrying
the princess and he reveals that the
general who recently died was next in
line for the throne and his son was
originally supposed to be a candidate
for the princess's hand in marriage this
shocks guts and he wonders if there's
more to Griffith than meets the eye
later that night word gets out that guts
has decided to leave the group and
everybody tries to convince him to stay
koska begs him to stay and he's even
stopped by Griffith Griffith challenges
guts to a duel in exchange for his
freedom to draw swords and griffith
charges at him thinking that the battle
will be over just like he did in the
beginning with Griffith winning and him
continuing to serve Griffith's dream
that's when he realizes that the battle
is over for him Griffith's sword was
broken and guts has now won the duel and
has won his freedom Griffith drops to
his niece in shock and everybody is
stunned and koska gets even more sad
than she even realizes one day later
Griffith sneaks into the princess's room
looking really defeated and she like an
idiot lets him in and asks if he's okay
Griffith ignores her words and quickly
gets busy with her and that's when one
of the dirty dirty Maids sneaks a peek
on the princess just to check on her and
she sees Griffith in bed with the
princess she runs away in shock and the
next day Griffith leaves the princess's
room but gets caught red-handed
meanwhile the king orders Griffith's men
and koska to head to this empty field
for a training practice without any of
their armor or weapons and suddenly they
hear the terrifying high-pitched Roar of
arrows raining down from the sky and
they realize that they've been set up
dozens of men die in seconds and casca
orders her men to think fast and charge
directly towards the archers barely
making it out alive and escaping
meanwhile hound dog angel face Griffith
is now being tortured and he is told
that he must be punished for getting
nasty with the princess and the King's
Men leave him in the hands of this short
thing this short Hunchback of Notre Dame
guy prepares to rip off the skin off of
Griffith's flesh and that's when he
notices a strange looking necklace he
jumps and rips it off but then it stares
at him and startles him causing him to
drop the necklace as a rolls down into
the sewers months later Griffith lays
destroyed in this dungeon mentally and
physically brutalized and then he
notices this necklace turned into this
terrifying monster and it crawls to him
and he has a vision of this unknown
Angel all the while as his necklace
floats away down this River elsewhere
koska and her group are now Outlaws and
she gets word that after months of
searching they finally located where
Griffith is being held oh such a bad
idea look I get it well he may be a
powerful fast slashing medieval cowboy
who is absolutely got a gorgeous face
his horny butt has literally ruined
everything these guys are acting way too
chill about it they think that
everything's going to turn back to
normal no and on top of that or even
more idiots what are they doing they're
lighting way too many campfires look all
over the place campfires everywhere what
are they doing they are making
themselves visible as hell listen the
punishment for the lowest level of
crimes during the Middle Ages was
getting your head chopped off and if we
think about what Griff did he did some
thanks to the King's Daughter which
means that anybody associated with him
would probably face the most horrifying
punishment imaginable death by Rad
Bracken oh means death by breaking the
wheel this is what awaits us this is
what awaits them if they go save
Griffith based on the seriousness of his
crimes this is why I would maybe say
something super unpopular at the moment
and say oh heck yes maybe we should
leave him be it's presumable that being
the Middle Ages means that during this
time period mercenaries are extremely
common throughout the world which means
that we can always find somewhere else
to find work which means if they just
leave the kingdom if they just bail on
Griffith right now they can find
somewhere else where they don't have any
history or they'll be able to start
fresh and not have any complicated
allegiances bottom line what do you want
money you need money to survive this
means that somebody within the battle of
the hawk should convince everybody else
as a group to ditch Griffith go find
somewhere else where they will get paid
bank and not have the kingdom of that
land try to chase them down and ruin
their lives but then out of nowhere they
hear terrifying screams outside of the
tent and her men begin getting
slaughtered to left and right she runs
out and yells for everybody to get ready
for combat these boomerangs nearly cut
her head off this assassin appears from
the shadows and quickly overpowers kaska
and he demands that she calls off her
men right now or he'll cut off her head
and three seconds resisting the Assassin
gets ready to make her death Swift but
then he gets pulled off my guts he's
returned he faces against this enemy
releases his Thunderclap blades but guts
uses his sword to create a freaking
storm and breaks his weapons with more
manliness than anime Chuck Norris guts
forces the rest of the bad guys to
retreat the men here update guts on what
happened with Griffith and he is shocked
the next morning he goes to talk about
it more with koska but she starts
attacking him she is furious with him
and says that he ruined Griffith and the
band of the Hawks the moment he left
guts finally has a realization and lets
kuska stab him he feels guilty for what
he's done and sees the sadness in her
eyes and she tries to go swimming with
the fishes but guts catches her last
minute he calls her crazy and she
approaches him and says that he is
always getting cut because of her and
she plants a big kiss right on him and
then they get busy medieval style but
then suddenly guts has a terrifying
vision of a monster he tries to choke it
but the hallucination then ends and
realizes that he is choking kaska oops
he apologizes and finally tells her his
traumatic life story it's very sad blah
blah blah blah blah go go watch the
anime he prepares to leave her but she
hugs him he tells her that there is no
point in licking each other's wounds but
she tells him that she is not leaving
and they both lick each other's wounds
wink wink later guts wakes up but senses
something approaching him he grabs his
sword and hears a voice whisper out to
him this terrifying Warrior approaches
him from the mist and warns him of
what's to come soon he will go crazy
with anger and will be forced to go
through the hardest Battle of his life
but whatever happens he tells guts to
struggle defy and strive to live and
then the stranger disappears without a
trace later gut's team sneaks into this
castle and the princess from earlier who
apparently was really impressed with
guts the first time helps guide them to
Griffith's dungeon heading down this
dark Corridor the princess informs them
of what lays ahead at this bottom of
this pit telling them of a terrifying
creature that ruled the world a thousand
years ago but one man managed to stop it
named the Skull King defeating the evil
he created a great Empire but got two
arrogant and his army was eventually
destroyed by the five Angels sent by God
kaska thinks it was only four Angels but
they don't think about too much of that
detail reaching Griffith's cage they
open it are horrified by what they see
Griffith starved skinned somehow alive
and his tongue was cut out and his
tendons cut so he can't escape guts
crumbles and hugs the out of his
skinny almost dead bro and then the cage
door closes and then short Quasimodo
excitedly announces that he's caught the
band of the Hawks guts Furious bashes
through the door and he sends this guy
to his Doom to then hear guards
approaching them and koska tells them
they need to run but guts loses his
and sweeps through these men like a wave
of death using their corpses as Shields
he leads the way out a one-man Army and
the princess helps them Escape rushing
out of the castle with Griffith they
realize that they are being chased and
the reign of arrows comes crashing down
in front of the guts and this guy
quickly do their job and managed to
escape the king's armies and make a
clean getaway later that night the band
of the Hawks here but having Griffith
back because everything's gonna be
better now that he's back there idiots
koska talks to this kid and he gives her
the diagnosis for Griffith telling her
that he will never be able to walk or
hold a sword again koska is shocked and
she struggles to gather everyone and
tell them the bad news the crew is left
speechless and begs koska to lead them
instead but she tells them she needs
time to think later the man get
desperate and beg guts to form a new
mercenary group instead okay this is
heartbreaking this is so sad but this is
also the perfect chance to drop Griffith
like an empty used up chocolate rapper
let me explain right now we've been put
in a seriously good opportunity to make
some lemonades out of some really nasty
lemons we can't let this go to waste if
I'm guts I'm going to take charge and
lead the group with kaska as my boo
cause leaders get lonely because think
about it Costco is a good warrior but
she doesn't have that Red Bull energy
that we talk about that guts has in huge
supply he's a one-man Army because look
at it Griffith this point finally lacks
the sexy muscle bot that we got which
means that all those hours that we've
spent put in the gym has finally paid
off and me taking over would increase
our ban of the Hawk's reputation to
clientele which we would easily be able
to get more clients because everybody
knows about guts full of Adventure and
fun guts agrees but later finds out from
Costco that she feels guilty about
Griffith and can't leave him then guts
has the old switch Rue and says that you
know what he'll stays well but she tells
him that he must go just then inside
Griffith's Caravan he then suddenly sees
a Shining Light and a kid approaches him
it's his younger self and he tells older
Griffith that he must go to his Destiny
the Caravan starts moving as guts and
koska realize guts chases after him and
he sees Griffith crash and fall into the
lake just then the world has an eclipse
guts runs to Griffith but sees monsters
beginning to appear all around him
making contact with Griffith the world
around them suddenly changes to
something
horrible thousands of heads filled the
floor around them and everyone begins
panicking guts picks up Griffith and
they hear from the monsters that the
festival is about to commence a feast
that happens once every 216 years and
the Monsters begin to hail the incoming
Four Angels one of the Angels then rises
from the ground Archangel Sloan the
world erupts around guts and all of his
men and more Angels appear from the sky
the demons begin cheering as all the men
stare on in sheer horror Griffith thinks
that these beings are Gods but guts
knows that they're Devils the Fallen
Angels welcome the humans to their
sacred nocturnal festival and tell
everyone that Griffith was selected by
law of causality and means that he was
meant to be here and they declare that
he was selected to be the Blessed king
of longing but guts tells them to go
screw themselves they all laugh and tell
him that guts you will make the perfect
sacrifice and everyone finds out that
the Angels around them will sacrifice
all of them in order to make Griffith a
demon king he was is qualified to become
one the moment he obtained the Crimson
egg revealing to everyone that receiving
the Egg of the king as how they are
reborn as God Hand Guardian Angels the
demons around them begin licking their
lips and the angels announced that
Griffith must choose to become a demon
king himself and Gus doesn't think that
Griffith is evil enough to do it and
that was his biggest mistake the
invocation of Doom begins and they bring
Griffith to the altar shooting up from
the ground beneath their feet guts hangs
on to dear life but Griffith lets go of
his hand forcing Gus to use his weapon
to cling onto the wall himself meanwhile
Griffith now laying in front of these
demon gods they tell him that he must
learn about himself first and they show
him a vision of his kid self realizing
that his dream of obtaining his own
kingdom is on top of millions of dead
people and he starts crying because he
soon realizes that he must obtain his
dream that he must be okay with the
murder of millions because what is a man
without power and then he suddenly comes
back to reality and the angels tell
Griffith that he just saw the truth
within his own Consciousness they tell
him that all of his men are what is left
for his final journey and the angels
offer up their powers and tell Griffith
to say the words I say sacrifice in
order to receive them and Justin guts
climbs back up and calls out to Griffith
he looks at guts approaching and tells
him that he was the only one who ever
made him forget about his dreams and he
thanks him and he utters the words of
the devil suddenly a wall closes around
in front of Griffith and cuts off guts
the sky then crashes down upon everyone
and all humans get branded for sacrifice
and then terrifying creatures begin
showing up left and right even more and
begin attacking gut's men quickly
slaughtering them becoming food for
Griffith the new child of Darkness
Costco looks on in shock as this guy
saves her and tells her to run and then
she gets saved by blonde guy who tells
her that she is now their leader and
that the band of the hawk will survive
with her but he quickly gets injured and
dies in koska's arms and she sees more
demons approaching her meanwhile on the
outside of this dark portal one of the
band of the hawk members this kid
finally arrives but sees something
strange in the distance and sees a
warrior battle but meanwhile back inside
gut tries to reach Griffith but the
Angels Above of him tell him that
Griffith doesn't want to be reduced and
more demons try to stop guts but he
brutally murders any that approach him
and he finally gets knocked down this
ledge and lands in a river of corpses
and blood and he sees one of his friends
in the distance and runs to him and just
then he gets ripped in half by this
smiling demon eating him right in front
of guts and he gets surrounded by more
hungry demons and then Griffith gets
granted wings and turns into the fifth
Angel Guts rushes to see Griffith and
tries to call out to him but that's when
Griffith reveals kaska Gus is horrified
and tries to go after her but he gets
one of his arms trapped in the monster's
mouth and guts is then forced to see and
hear things that he wish he had never
seen before unable to do anything he
begins to lose his mind and starts
chopping off his trapped arm and breaks
it off from the bone and he charges
towards Griffith but is stopped by his
powers but even then guts almost
overpowers Griffith shocking the Angels
but then he gets sent up flying into the
air and slams onto the floor a demon
then quickly holds him down kaska barely
alive tells him to not look and the
angels from above adore the love between
guts and koska and then guts gets one of
his eyes stabbed with Griffith's cold
stare being the last thing he sees but
then the eclipse breaks and down comes
the one man who can stop this the Skull
King he tries to attack one of the
Angels but misses but he carries on and
comes charging down killing all the
demons that he encounters Griffith tries
to kill him but he is too quick and
disappears from where he came from he
exits the portal showing up to the kid
from earlier but this time carrying guts
in koska in tow the Angels then
announced that since the fifth angel has
arrived an epic of Darkness shall soon
arrive that man will soon live in a
world known as the age of Darkness Days
Later guts wakes up in a cave missing an
eye and an arm the kid from earlier
arrive and tells him that they've been
taking care of them he asks him what
happened to all the rest of the men but
then guts remembers koska and he rushes
over to see her but realizes something
is off as he approaches her she flinches
and looks scared he tries to calm her
down but she runs away to hide behind
this little girl the boy tells him that
she has no memory of anything and is
gone insane got begins to cry in horror
and escapes into the forest running for
hours until he collapses defeated in
this field and then suddenly he hears
some noise and sends his demons
approaching him wanting his branded
flesh the Skull King then arrives and
reminds him of what he's told to stay
alive no matter what guts has been
marked for sacrifice so demons will
never stop hunting him and then guts
remembers what Griffith did and his rage
motivates him to continue fighting to
save the world mostly for Revenge though
and he grabs one of the skull King's
weapons and picks off the remaining
ghosts he goes full on crazy and plans
to send all of God's angels back to hell
with one arm and he finally realizes his
own dream which is to stop the demons to
save the world to kill Griffith and
restore koska but what do you think
about the video don't forget to like
subscribe and leave a comment down below
and as always don't forget to check out
our how to be playlist